allez nous on va ouvrir maintenant notre
grande bibliothèque elle est avec nous
Tiphaine pour la sélection livre
jeunesse du moment et aujourd'hui vous
êtes venu avec des livres poétiques qui
encourage nos enfants à se relever quand
ils tombent histoire de suivre leur rêve
c'est une sacre ambition oui parce
qu'elle est ce n'est pas qu'une question
théorique un comment reprendre pied une
fois qu'on est tombé puisque vous le
savez certainement les jeunes enfants
tombent à peu près 10 fois par jour et
les parents ne savent pas toujours
comment réagir il y a le oh tu t'es pas
fait mal ou non tu n'as certainement pas
mal alors avec ce livre justement qui
s'appelle même pas mal de Sarah gavoli
publié chez soy jeunesse et bien ils
sauront exactement quoi dire puisque
l'auteur pose la question à cette petite
fille et lui dit bah tu es tombé doux
d'une marche d'escalier du lit de tes
parents et elle dit toujours non non et
les questions deviennent de plus en plus
farfelues ça finit par tuer ton bébé bah
voilà des montagnes russes tu es tombé
du toit du poulailler tu es tombé du dos
d'un éléphant
évidemment du coup c'est drôle la petite
fille oublie sa douleur et nous on
s'amuse beaucoup c'est un livre pour les
petits à partir de 2 ans mais vous
pouvez le lire aussi Pascal d'accord
je vois le papa qui est à côté de vous
particulièrement sensible votre fille
est plus grande mais forcément vous avez
été confronté à ce genre de situation
son enfant qui tombe voilà évidemment
que ça soit mon fils ou ma fille
effectivement ils sont tous tombés
tous tout le temps donc c'est normal
mais après c'est les couleurs sont
magnifiques regardez le graphisme c'est
extraordinaire
j'aime beaucoup bon parfois aussi c'est
l'empressement et la fatigue qui nous
font commettre des erreurs je sais de
quoi je parle ça consomme pas que des
petits n'est-ce pas mais là c'est dans
un livre suédois avec l'histoire d'une
maman pressée oui ça s'appelle
d'ailleurs une maman si pressée de Sarah
Lemberg et en fait bien c'est une
journée un peu folle comme il y en
arrive souvent quand on a beaucoup de
choses à faire on suit Noah un petit
garçon un petit peu étourdi et sa maman
qui doivent aller faire du shopping
trouver un cadeau d'anniversaire
et puis arrivé à l'heure à cet
anniversaire et rien ne se passe comme
prévu ils oublient un vêtement ils
perdent le cadeau bref c'est un peu la
catastrophe mais ce livre est très
tendre assez sensible il y a pas de
jugement sur cette maman qui veut bien
faire et sur ce petit garçon qui
finalement la console à la fin de la
journée donc c'est un très joli livre je
vous le conseille pour les enfants à
partir de 4,5 ans puisque finalement et
bien il y a toujours des solutions et
puis les enfants seront assez touchés
par cette histoire puisque tous les
enfants vous disent à la fin mais arrête
de me presser pourquoi tu es si
catastrophique pourquoi tu veux faire
tout si bien donc c'est un livre que je
vous conseille voilà c'est très joli
c'est une petite histoire mignonne
on respecte l'imitation de vitesse pour
aller sur la coupe Moto Légende sur le
circuit du genre prenant en plus il y
aura des il y aura en sortie ce week-end
des vérifications comment dire voilà
donc vous y allez vous y allez Mollo
donc je suis plus les motards ils y vont
sur les motos anciennes
en général il y a pas de il y a pas
vraiment de souci tout le monde respecte
les lieux les limitations et dans une
belle ambiance bon on revient à la
bibliothèque de vous êtes formidable sur
France 3 ne pas chuter et prendre son
envol c'est aussi le thème des livres
suivants oui alors celui-là qui
s'appelle je suis ton manteau est une
femme d'Angélique Villeneuve et Julien
Martinière c'est publié à l'étagère du
bas et l'histoire et bien c'est celle
d'Igor vous savez il y a des petits
garçons comme ça qui sont très timides
et qui ont peur de tout peur de sortir
peur d'aller un petit peu plus loin de
s'éloigner de la maison un jour son papa
a une idée il se dit je vais te faire un
manteau avec des plumes d'oiseaux
ramassés dans la nature comme ça tu
n'auras plus peur d'y aller et il fait
des ailes à ce manteau des ailes qui
sont cachées dans la doudoune alors on
ne sait pas trop si c'est le manteau qui
est magique ou si c'est le regard de la
petite voisine qui l'encourage mais en
tout cas ce livre est très joli c'est
une femme pleine de légèreté assez
touchante c'est pareil je vous le
conseille pour les enfants à partir de
élémentaires ça fait toujours du bien de
savoir qu'on a des ailes dans le dos
pour prendre son envol dites moi sur les
Coupes Moto légendes de Xavier vous avez
fait un livre qui regroupe justement
toutes ces éditions parce que il y a eu
des trésors à chaque fois non mais on y
pense l'année prochaine c'est la 30e
édition
donc on va pas trop grandir mais
effectivement parfait bon un dernier
roman on l'a dit pour les ados tiens
vous me parlez tout à l'heure des ailes
moi je pense à Iker il s'appelle pas
Iker j'ai l'impression mais Peter
celui-là oui il s'appelle Peter peton et
contrairement à son nom il a pas du tout
les pieds sur terre et c'est un livre de
Maël fierpier alors on entend encore le
petit mot là à pied c'est pas tout à
fait anodin ça s'appelle le prodigieux
destin de Peter et l'histoire est assez
farfelue ce petit garçon qui ne parle
pas qui est un peu dans son monde arrive
dans une usine de fabrication de
chaussons celle de Monsieur pantoufle et
se retrouve ensevelisse sous une pâte un
petit peu bizarre son corps se modifie
et des ailes dans le dos alors je ne
vous en dis pas plus c'est farfelu c'est
drôle s'étendre on ne lâche pas ce livre
c'est publié
à l'édition médium donc c'est pour les
ados et puis ça tombe bien que je parle
d'elle pour prendre son envol parce que
j'ai vu qu'il y en avait aussi la sur
tous les petits goodies de la Coupe Moto
Légende donc je pense qu'on est dans le
thème
d'ailleurs vous savez non parce que il y
a des logos un petit peu motards ou de
marque qui qui ont des ailes et puis là
et puis ouais et puis la moto donne des
ailes donc